wow that is a spoiler I know there's an
episode where Finn's a girl okay it's
like you grounded
like Jason that's why he's not in this
yeah he's grounded too I never knew how
powerful just saying that was like you
just say you're grounded it's like
people listen mom it's like we just have
the authority yes yeah
quite impressive yeah well while we're
on the subject grounded is a big focus
on this one this is a hitman and it's
another Ice King episode which I'm sure
made you very happy and if you got this
episode okay first of all the opening of
this this is like that's some of my
favorite design that's it's in like out
of its breakfast land or whatever but
it's like breakfast princess and her
sister who I guess is also a breakfast
princess good question breakfast
princesses yeah I was gonna say if
there's two of them do they have like
distinct names or is it just breakfast
princess one in front breakfast princess
- it's a tongue twister and that's and
they look nothing alike one's like a
piece of toast and the other it's just
like a human and just the the design of
both of them is great and the layout
which is like this giant orange tree
like some are even being squeezed into
this glass just I friggin love dat you
remind me of like those old 80s
breakfast compare just like I want to be
in this place that's awesome um so I
love the designs on man I loved how it
was so quick - it wasn't even like a big
focus so that that made even funnier so
Ice King comes he's not really doing
anything that bad he's just giving her
honey I which really isn't that yeah is
that you surly Ice King to really do
anything wrong it's like are you trying
to poison her you try to put some spell
it is like no I'm just kidding huh honey
it's like that was it
so yeah so been a Jake ground
he just listen I'd say like I said just
like about you hearing the words your
ground it's like Oh which I think it's
one of those things like where until you
become a parent you're just sort of
helpless to it it's like until it
suddenly you have the authority but
until there's like somebody just says
it's like oh it's like this habitat you
just had to kind of listen so he goes to
his ice Kingdom whatever it's called
stay there to grab doesn't mean go get
groceries that's how you ground him
because that's actually a very gross
arees you have a big problem sir sound
like a couple mountain dudes to be fair
there's still around
that's that she is a very cool way to
grab someone just like you do some
chores get some stuff done sheesh um so
okay so he's like olive oil or some way
I could hit that man so he looks for a
hitman called the scorcher which might
be one of my new favorite character he
doesn't say thing you don't really see
his baby he's just awesome
he's guy's face all wrapped up he can
control fire he sir like the ghost of
Christmas future he doesn't talk and
he's just very creepy and he can turn to
smoke and disappear and he thinks he
wants it where do exactly one sounds
like hey you know be a hitman and kill
them so he can't see tries to kill them
and Ice King keeps stop him no I just
want you to hit him like in the shoulder
but that's not enough for the guy like
the contract has to be honored it's like
very samurai is she you know just the
honor of it and you know he's signed
something you made a promise even if the
person doesn't want the problem is it
wants to break it he has to follow
through and this job think about yeah
it's there's just reputation on the line
yeah it served like in on the one hand
it makes no sense on the other hand it's
sort of like you have that respect idea
it's like he has to follow through even
if the person doesn't want it anymore
you know which is like the whole purpose
of doing in the first place but but you
still kind of get it it's like it's I
don't know why we get it we just sort of
do you know it's not even like te ha ha
he's so stupid it's like no like you
really get this sense of falling all the
way with something and the Ice King
tricks him into thinking he killed them
now here's the big question though is
that he freezes up and says no their
pulse is not going they're dead and
everything and the guy he unfreezes one
of the arms and actually checks the
pulse and agrees and he leaves but it's
like so did the Ice King really kill
it's like you know the show keeps going
but it's like in the next episode do
they really have to bring them back to
life somehow or something or is it just
like that's part of being frozen I don't
know well you can't you can actually
have your heart stopped for I don't know
I think yeah I guess for tonight very
short amount maybe less than a minute
before brain damage sets in so if you
kind of think of like cryogenics and
stuff and maybe it's like his curd way
of like freezing them I guess maybe
maybe a scorcher just doesn't know about
ice science or whatever and there was
the name of the other hit man that the
hit man for the hill yeah and he just
comes and just starts shooting
everything looks like an Atari hero and
then like he gets his ass handed to me
runs away and it just well no is this
giant robot it's been yet any runs yeah
so it looks back and you see his little
button Ice King Peaks over and they kind
of meet their eyes and they're like ooh
I love what's in this one I must have
heard you're sawing your love of the
song and say we have one more butts in
this so they can be punched I like I
like the I like camicazi saying look at
my now look over there and just him not
turning if I like just you know they
actually trust her it at some point
where'd you get with you kind of know
what's coming but I think with this
character because he has such a presence
and is such a threatening presence is so
funny that he would eventually fall for
it
so no I did I thought it was great I
really like this character and I like
the fact that they establish Ice King
really would not kill them like he would
probably threaten them with that but he
wouldn't actually follow through it back
he'd even admit I screwed up he wants to
kill you but you know we we gotta stop
this so I got a you know like there is
service like he finds him annoying it
interference but he wouldn't still stoop
to the law of actually killing them you
know so there is still serve like this
nice connection with them in a sense so
yeah I really liked it this solidifies
for me right now what I've always
thought about Ice King which isn't that
he's actually that he's not really a
villain even though he's kind of
portrayed as one and he kind of is Oh
Ice King but I feel like even from the
beginning I always felt like he's not so
much a villain as this poor sad sack who
just has like no social skills what he
just does the wrong thing not because
he's a horrible person but just kids he
just doesn't know any better and like
this whole thing just everything for me
it's like yeah this is what I've been
thinking about the whole time yeah he's
pissed at Finn and Jake and and you know
but he didn't want them dead he doesn't
want them dead he just I'm gonna punch
you your bones so maybe so maybe that's
something that comes back and maybe he
does want to at some point it's that'd
be interesting the plot would thicken
but you know I like this character I
like even for a second just that one
hitman of a hitman hey just just a great
concept it's just funny I never thought
about just like a hit man up a hit man
you know it just sounds like I like the
fact that their internet is also like in
8 bits I just think that's really funny
like everything this world is 8 bits and
very retro and stuff and just the idea
of their internet being that way too and
I thought was very funny and yeah try
think there's anything else
well was that did you think of meat man
ok so yes what Metro
our that eating a person called meat man
he's made of meat where did you get the
meat from meat man hey do you do you
think it hurts meat man to give us meat
I think that's probably one of the most
horrific things like we should stop
eating meat man but here's the thing it
could be we should stop eating meat
comma man no I'm pretty sure they said
they wanted but isn't that horrific and
and the fact that they just kind of say
it is an afterthought like you really
have to listen to really kind of
understand and just like let it soak in
oh my god you got your meat from meat
man and you don't even know if it hurts
him or not to give you me oh my god it's
a very cannibalistic if but why would he
give it if it hurt him I mean that I
don't know but he's meat man so clearly
that's his purpose in life is
maybe it's like getting a haircut maybe
they're eating his hair maybe his hair
is like salami like slices of salami I
would actually be cool I would like that
this V log is unacceptable tweeks
dungeon
you're all the worst the worst so what
do you guys say about this episode
unacceptable